listening to a film
and Kerry Wood
well I want to go back to what he just
said about making everything transparent
and telling everyone what your budget is
I don't see filmmakers doing that
because a lot of them still hold out
some hope that they're going to get some
kind of distribution some way and
they're not going to tell a distributor
how much they made their film for
because that automatically sets the bar
how much you would get paid if there was
any upfront pay I know filmmaker I've
ever talked to you has ever wanted to
share their budget with me they'll tell
me a range but they won't tell me a
number Senate is doing is really showing
how how much people want to help each
other I mean sites life and you can look
like couch Crashers for example i mean i
was in tokyo I've had a number of people
stay with me you know i anticipate i'm
going to be staying with other people
and its total strangers from other
countries and i'm inviting them into my
home and getting to know them and you
know giving them a place to crash for
free and there's more and more things
like this popping up because of i think
the internet and i honestly believe
people want to connect in a genuine way
and support each other I think we need
to be not so insular I don't think our
target audience is other indie
filmmakers I think our target audience
are alternative lifestyle people who are
more into the arts and entertainment who
are vegans who are gay and lesbian who
are you know bite writers I don't know
they're there people who who are more
interested in other voices and diverse
content and all these sites seem to
target independent filmmakers it's just
being a filmmaker making a film and
seeing what the options are out there
for once you're done with the film David
I know you're making a film to have
imagining you're going through what most
filmmakers are going through which is
you have a film it's done it has a fan
base but you can't make money and you
don't have really many options out there
to continue your work as a filmmaker so
there's no model currently out there for
filmmakers to be able to sustain and
make films that they feel passionate
about and so I I've been thinking long
and hard for a year and a half to try to
come up with a solution of the problem